Hello.
Welcome to the next live workshop and the
complete guide to Teleport.
Today, we are taking a look at database
access once more.
Previously, we took a look at using Teleport
to provide access to Postgres clusters.
Today, we're taking a look at how to
do the same with MongoDB.
Today's workshop should be around thirty minutes long,
give or take,
where we are going to use Teleport
and MongoDB together,
and it's gonna be fun and good to
work.
Yes.
So if you're joining us live, thank you
very much. I see Kevin in the chat.
Hey, man. How's it going?
I have pushed
today's material to GitHub.
So if I pop over
to our screen share,
you will see that we are back with
the Rawkode Academy
slash courses repository on github.com,
where we have a directory called nine database
access MongoDB.
Here we have exercise
one through eight, where we are going to
take a look
at how to get secure access
as as the ethos of Teleport, right, security
everywhere
to
our MongoDB
server.
Now I actually really like MongoDB,
so I'm quite excited to play with this
and get this working.
We also have Russell on the chat. Hey.
Welcome back. Nice to see you again.
So there are a couple of prerequisite.
Oh, hey, Moz. The whole gang's here.
Oh, and thank you for noticing, Russell. That
audio sounds much better today.
I have I am I am spending too
much time, and I'm spending more time worrying
about my audio than I should be, but
I I'm just trying to get it right
for the acoustics in this new office. And
everything's been pulled back today, a lot less
processing, and hopefully that kinda makes it just
sound a bit better.
Previously, when I had my home office, I
was trying to process out
young children,
animals,
hardwood floating,
and just all those settings came with me
to my new space, and they were just
far too much overkill.
So I'm glad that's done some better.
Cool.
Okay. We have a few prerequisites for today's
session.
One, Teleport,
obviously. We've covered that plenty so far. You
should all be complete experts at installing Teleport
and getting that ready to go.
You're going to need a MongoDB server.
This is an app install away.
The
installation of MongoDB I have today is just
an app install. There's nothing special about it.
We haven't tweaked anything yet. We're gonna be
doing that right now.
And I have a local
session authenticated
against the Teleport cluster that I set up.
So all the prerequisites are ticked, we should
be good to go.
And the first thing we needed to do
is prepare our MongoDB.
So MongoDB
has authentication by default
and has a special system for configuring external
authorization,
which we can see here.
So really we need to connect to our
MongoDB server
using the mongocli.
We are going to end the external DB,
run a command,
and that command is to create a user.
MongoDB has always been really good at using
X509 for its authentication, for as long as
I can remember, even going back to like
2013,
maybe even earlier.
So you'll see that the create user has
a common name of Rawkode and this just
fits in with the way that they handle
their authentication.
We don't have roles here, we're saying that
we want to allow the read rate on
any database where that database is admin. So
we're given Rawkode
user
read rate
to the admin system.
First question from Avanesh.
Welcome to the workshop. Does this work with
managed MongoDB Atlas or does it have to
be self hosted?
I had to consider doing Atlas as well.
And in fact, you may we made Wing
Atlas.
I reckon we're gonna get through self hosted
really, really quickly. This was the easiest thing
I've ever had to set up. So maybe
we'll just take a pop at doing Atlas.
I did create an Atlas cluster and the
off chance that I felt like winging it,
but every time I wing stuff, it gets
me into trouble. So
and we'll see how we go. But it
does work with Atlas and we can maybe
work through the documentation and get that working
today.
So let's see how we get on with
self hosted,
and then
I'll let I'll let you all decide what
we do next.
Right. Where's my cursor? Okay. So what do
we need to do? First,
I'm gonna connect
to my
machine.
If I run a p it's probably a
bit small for you all.
Run a ps a ux grep
-i
mongo.
You will see that we have our MongoDB
running
and this has been running for the last
thirty five minutes.
If I run
Mongo command,
it draws me into the Mongo shell.
The Mongo shell is pretty much like a
console that accepts JavaScript or at least a
weird form of JavaScript for interacting with the
MongoDB
API.
So if we pop back over here,
we can just copy and paste this.
And we get an okay one.
Wing it. Wing it. Wing it. Wing it.
Thanks. Thanks, Russell.
We we we can wing it. I'm pretty
confident we could do it. Given how easy
self hosted it, hopefully, the Atlas one shouldn't
be too painful.
Okay. So we have created our external authentication,
a user call Rawkode with access to the
admin database.
Next task. And you, if you paid attention
or watched the Postgres one, this command is
almost the exact same.
So now that we can just drop out
of the Mongo shell, we just do a
control D or X set wherever your poison
is.
And from here, we can run AT controls
to Teleport Control
off sign,
and this time we're passing in a format
of MongoDB,
and we have to pass in the
MongoDB
host name.
And very much similar to the Postgres one,
the host name that we use here has
to be the host name that
Teleport proxy, the DB proxy,
will speak to and connect to your database.
So
I'm pretty confident I went with MongoDB and
not Mongo, but, you know, doesn't hurt to
confirm.
Yeah.
Cool.
So we're going to use a MongoDB dot
Rawkode dot SH, which is just pointing
to my VM.
Mozz, question from Mozz. Why are you putting
CN equals before the Rawkode user?
When you're working with x five zero nine
certificates,
there's no concept of the username.
Typically, we use the common name.
So the CN stands for common name and
the common name equals Rawkode. It's just how
I am identified by the system.
Great question.
Okay. The format out or the file name
is going to be Mongo, and I'm happy
for this token to live for the next
forty eight hours, which is far longer than
this virtual machine will be living for.
So we're gonna run this
and because, you know, I said this during
the postgres video, but the fact that the
t control, Teleport Control Command is is telling
us how to do this is really, really
cool.
So it's saying, hey, we have generated
the certificate and the certificate authority
and these two files.
If we want to enable mutual TLS on
your MongoDB server, we have to update it
with this configuration.
So the first thing we need to do
is get these files into a location that
makes a little bit more sense.
So I'm just going to do a move
mongostar
etc.
We pop into
if you see
and grep,
we'll see that we have these files.
So
the first stuff, the next thing I wanna
do is that I know
that if I run system control cat mongod,
that the user and group for the MongoDB
service as MongoDB.
So I just wanna make sure that
the MongoDB user can read these certificates and
probably nobody else. So with that in mind,
we'll do MongoDB,
Mongo star.
And if we do our GREP again,
here we go.
So that looks much better. I think that
is in a position where we can now
configure our MongoDB
process.
Now, if I scroll up, I can just
copy and paste
the configuration that was given to us by
Teleport Control Off-site.
We're gonna drop this into our mongod.conf
and we can just put this anywhere. I'm
just gonna go straight down the bottom
and then we have to tell it where
we put those certificates.
So
Like so.
And save.
So now we've modified
the MongoDB configuration.
We are gonna have to restart MongoDB.
This is a systemd service.
MongoDB.
It's always useful
to check the logs for any errors.
This appears
to be okay. It stopped it. It started
it. And I can just make sure by
checking the log folder where we have the
MongoDB log.
It's waiting for connections.
I'm pretty happy that MongoDB
is now configured
with the certificates that were provided by Teleport.
Cool.
So we got a question there.
Mozz asking,
so Teleport
will cert based authentication with MongoDB. Yeah. Teleport
issues x five zero nine certificates for almost
everything that it does,
but Mongo
already had awesome support for x five zero
nine and and mutual TLS. So,
match made in heaven as far as these
two projects are going.
And, Kevin, thanks for answering that in the
chat too.
Okay.
So we did our sign, we configured Mongo.
Now
what we've done so far is just prepare
MongoDB.
Much like the Postgres session, we now have
to run that DB proxy that is gonna
facilitate the connections to Mongo.
So we are going to generate a database
token.
Like so.
Again, we're getting all the commands given to
us. Okay. Maybe this is what you wanna
do.
I am just going to
I always call it a. Sh. I should
call it dbproxy.
Sh.
We're going to just copy the command from
here
and we'll run through this in just a
second.
Woah.
Set paste.
And now we just wanna copy
the token.
So if we go into our DB
I'm
in the Etsy folder, I didn't realize, which
means I had a conflict, which is why
my tab wasn't as instant as I expected
it to be.
So we've got TeleportDB start. We can pop
in our token, deleting that dot. We don't
need that. Our auth server is available at
Rawkode
no. Teleport.
Rawkode. Ssh on port 443.
I'm going to name this database proxy MongoDB.
The protocol is MongoDB.
There is a second protocol option for Atlas,
MongoDB Atlas, which I've seen as I was
skimming the documentation earlier. So if we do
attempt to do that, we will need another
DB proxy with a different protocol
and a different URL.
And here, we're just saying that the URI
to speak to MongoDB is MongoDB,
MongoDB,
Rawkode,
SH, and then the MongoDB port. The MongoDB
port is two seven zero one seven.
Cool.
Now we can run our DB proxy,
and let's see what do we have.
Started successfully.
I like it when things work.
So that means using the Teleport
CLI,
like we do
every week of these sessions, is I can
use Teleport Control DB LS. Now I'm not
gonna do this locally.
I should be
status.
I
am logged on to the same Teleport cluster,
so I can do a DB LS.
And now we can see our MongoDB.
Cool.
Next, we wanna do the DB login.
So for that, we just do DB
login,
and we're gonna pass in the DB user.
So this is the user that we created
in the first step.
If we scroll back up here, the common
name was Rawkode.
So that means that when I log in,
the DB user is going to be Rawkode.
That is arbitrary and could have been anything
I want. It's just coincidence that it also
happens to be my Teleport username.
And then we wanna connect
MongoDB.
Now
when we run DBLS,
we will see that we have some extra
information that wasn't available prior, and that's just
because we've configured
that little bit of extra information. We didn't
provide a DB name, and so we could
do that on the connect if we want.
But what we can do as a DB
connect MongoDB.
Hello.
We are now in the stage of a
MongoDB shell,
proxied through Teleport.
Wonderful. Now, I don't remember a lot of
DB commands,
but you can see here that if I
do tab completion,
we get
we get things. So there's no local users
on this. There's
no local users created
on this
MongoDB
server, so we're just getting back an empty
one.
I believe if I switch to the external
DB, it would work.
Alright. So we can drop out of this,
pop back over here,
scroll down,
and
oh, did I leave that in the machine?
So when I tested this earlier, I forgot
to clean up one little thing. I'm gonna
remove it now just oh, no. It's not
there.
Alright.
I'm not gonna worry about that.
So what happened during my earlier testing
was the proxy that was trying to speak
to MongoDB,
which wasn't resolving to one two seven. So,
you know, I was able to add that
to the host file. So if you find
that you do a TSH DB connect and
you get that timed out for whatever reason,
the reason will be that the proxy has
gone over the public interface. Why is it
not? Oh, wait. This is my
this is my host file.
I am being very silly.
I'm gonna open a second session. Let's make
this let's break it. Right?
So I'm gonna open my host file.
Yep. Here's the entry here. So we're gonna
take this out.
Yeah. That's going over the public Internet now.
So let's try that one more time, and
I don't know if it's gonna be cached
by the proxy server now.
Yes, it's failing. Good.
So this is what happens
when you don't set that up, is that
the proxy,
which is on the VM, the same VM
as MongoDB,
uses the
host name to speak to MongoDB.
The problem with that is that it's going
out over the public interface. In fact, like
we said, we can resolve. Like I just
showed,
when I ping mongodb.
Rokode. Sh, we get a public IPv4
address.
However, the default configuration for MongoDB
is to lessen
or bind as they've got it here, but
either works,
is to bind on the one two seven
dot zero dot zero dot one loopback interface.
So public Internet traffic can't actually connect or
speak to this MongoDB server.
So the effects there is just like I
had in is to make sure that wherever
your proxy server runs
can resolve and connect to that MongoDB on
the local interface if required,
or modify your MongoDB and make it available
on
a
private subnet or even publicly if you're feeling
particularly brief.
We can put that back in and then
just like magic,
if I reconnect, it should drop us straight
in
to our shell.
Sweet.
Alright. Now we've got a few comments here.
Let me see if there were any questions.
Okay. Evan Ash is asking, I'm curious why
I ran the DB proxy one as a
script.
And no real rhyme or reason.
The only reason I made this a script
is just because it was easier to edit
the multiple lines that I had. You know,
if I were to copy and paste that
onto the command line,
and then I wanna modify one bit of
it, like,
I have to push back
and back
and then I'm gonna push up.
That's a bit awkward.
So by running it I
should have really put it in an empty
directory.
By putting it into Vim and just run
it as a script, I can now just
use a standard text editor to modify that.
That was the only reason you don't have
to. Of course, if you want your DB
proxy
to work and work well, then you're probably
just gonna wanna actually run that as a
system to be serviced anyway and not as
a random hacky script inside of the Etsy
folder.
Okay.
Kevin says, normally, you would have to set
the config.
Me pop that up. Normally, you have to
set the config and the Teleport config. Yeah.
You can also do it that way. So
it's
if we pop open
our Teleport YAML here, you can run a
DB service in here and configure it and
have it run as part of the main
process.
I tend to run all my app and
DB proxies just separately,
but that's just personal
opinion.
I don't have any real reason to recommend
it that way. It just means I've got
a bit more flexibility,
a bit more control,
and if I kill one of those or
one of those dies, it doesn't take down
my entire Teleport subsystem. Personal
preference, but do whatever works best in your
own situation.
Does Teleport support
session recording for MongoDB
access?
You know what, Mozz? I haven't looked.
Let's see.
So if we come to databases,
we can connect and get the same commands
that I was using earlier just for the
record.
But if I go to activity,
is there an active session?
That's my two web ones. Right?
Let's pop open
my DB again.
I'm just gonna hate your comment just now
so we can see.
Oh, I killed the proxy.
Okay. So proxy back up and running.
Connect.
Give me a shell.
Db dot get users.
Alright.
Sessions,
fresh.
Okay. So I don't think the sessions show
up here.
Session recording.
No. So I think it's just the audit
log stuff.
We can check the documentation in a minute.
So it could be that potentially
you can enable session recording for DBS, but
I'm not sure. But the audit log here
does show us everything that we're doing.
So we can see here that I'm in
the test database.
It should show me the query.
That's maybe not the query I just executed.
Let's run it again.
These are the two that were added.
Executed QWERTY and executed to QWERTY.
User info.
Documents. Yeah.
So I think this is just doing some
sort of translation of my query.
So I guess get users actually translate to
users info
where the documents came back as as empty.
So this is what we expect. We do
have
a audit log showing us that I actually
could do that query, but definitely doesn't
look like they're recorded.
However, we can jump onto the GoTeleport docs.
We can type in
database access.
Where is the Mongo gate?
Let's just tape it.
Oh, that's Atlas. We we can we'll go
back there in a minute.
Yeah. I don't think
there's any session recorded.
Alright. Well, you do have the audit log.
It's there,
which is very useful.
Alright. Let's see what else. I think there
was there's a couple more tasks.
One of my other favorite features is that
the Teleport
command
can just tell you the command that you
need to run locally in order to get
this to work. So, you know, if you
already have the Mongo CLI and you'd rather
just connect to standard tooling,
then you can pass format equals command to
it, and it just tells you what you
need to run.
And as we've seen with the Postgres one,
which I absolutely love,
is that you can run a proxy
DB locally,
which creates a bunch of search on your
system, and then you can use your own
your GUI tool of choice to also connect
to the thing.
I have never used MongoDB Compass before, but
as you can tell by this thing telling
me, you did not do this from the
Internet today.
So let's see if we can get the
MongoDB Compass UI speaking
to our Teleport exposed secure
MongoDB cluster.
And I see we've got a few more
comments coming in. Oops. Some spam. Need to
get that dealt with.
Evan Ash got answers to his question. Awesome.
Oh, Canal is watching and saying, my streams
are fun. Thanks, man. Thank you very much.
Session recording for databases and applications currently not
implemented. There's an issue open.
Alright. Super useful. Thank you, Kevin. So there
is an issue to make that work, And
I'll be I'm sure if I'm playing with
that as soon as that launches. That's gonna
be awesome.
Okay.
So my compass opened over
here.
Let's see what this thing's capable of.
Yeah. Let me connect to the thing. Okay.
So I wanna connect to MongoDB
local host
this port here.
And it's telling me I need to use
these certificates,
which I don't know how to do.
Let's work out that.
Authentication,
509.
More options?
Nope.
I mean, I'm saying 509.
So I need to turn on.
Okay.
Here we go. So I want server and
client verification.
So I can pick my certificate authority.
What is the key to show hidden fails?
I
don't remember.
Oh, MacPhail. I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm gonna Google it.
Oh, Moz. Right in there. Thanks, Moz. It
is command shift and dot.
You are awesome.
Ah, there we go.
So we wanna use TSH
keys,
Teleport.
This is my Rawkode DB one.
Is this CA
I wouldn't have thought so.
I'm gonna select it just now so that
the packer doesn't lose my directory,
but the CA is certs. Pem. Okay. So
it's up a directory.
There. The client cert
as the MongoPem.
Nice.
And the per
I have a key as the Rawkode file.
So let's back up again.
And there.
Does it work?
Hey.
Hey, there we go. Nice.
We now have access to
our Mongo server
through Teleport through the UI.
I've never used Compass before. I'm just gonna
click on a few things
just to see.
Can we create a collection?
Let's call it Howdy.
There we go. Cool.
I will perhaps play with Compass
in other day.
So we can shut down our
local proxy. So that's a great command, t
s h proxy,
and then you can do applications and DBs
if you've got them all configured properly through
the Teleport system. You provide the name, and
it just makes it available for you to
work with locally. Absolutely great feature.
And that is our 10 exercises
for connecting
to a secured MongoDB
cluster via Teleport.
I guess now is the big question.
Do we wing it and try Atlas?
I will give you all ten seconds to
do a thumbs up or a thumbs down
in the chat.
Go.
Come on, where's my thumbs down?
Bear in mind that the option, the alternative
to me winging the Atlas stuff is to
go home and have a beer. So would
you really want to deprive me of that?
I'm just saying.
One thumb up.
Two thumbs up.
The beer is delayed, I guess.
Okay. Let's just go for it. So
thanks, Evan Ash. I appreciate that. But we'll
we'll do it anyway. You know what? It's
gonna be fun.
And I have no problem going off script.
Can I have a plus one too?
Alright.
So
you can have a beer after drink faster.
Okay.
So let's shut down
that. We don't need this anymore.
Don't need my DB proxy anymore.
And we're going off script, so we don't
even need GitHub anymore. So, let's log in
to MongoDB Atlas. So, I did create a
cluster just in case we decided to go
for this.
Go go
Me.
Cool. Cluster zero. I picked a very unique
name.
And
the only things I prepared earlier in case
we tried this was network access,
which I believe is now wrong because I
actually
destroyed this VM anyway, and this is
my local current IP address. There you go.
Have that. Have some fun.
So
let's just expose this. So what we want
to do is go through the MongoDB Atlas
documentation,
and we're just gonna work through this. I
suspect this is gonna be extremely similar to
what we've just done with one or two
little changes.
So we don't need to configure our Teleport.
We have a working Teleport. Technically, have a
token, so but I'm gonna reuse that token.
And we have a d b start command
here, and I know the protocol
or the protocol is just MongoDB. Okay. But
there's we use a server record for the
URL,
and there's this
CA thing, which we're gonna have to navigate
to.
So let's pop over
to here.
I'm going in fact, you know, I'm going
to move that DB proxy script cause that
was annoying
to here,
and we'll modify the command based on what
we can see here. So
our token should be alright.
Our auth server is definitely okay.
We will rename this just in case
something conflicts between what was the old DB
proxy and this new one. Let's remove
any chance of this feeling, hopefully.
Protocol is still MongoDB
and the URL is different.
So URI
equals MongoDB
plus
SRV,
and then we need to put
our atlas address.
Okay.
Let's see if we can find that.
Do we have
an endpoint somewhere?
If I click connect,
shell.
Okay. Here we go.
So
let's
copy this
and tweak
what we think we need to.
So
paste. Oh, that's probably a bit small for
y'all to read through it. There we go.
Okay.
So srvcluster0.gdnssMongoDB.net
my
do I need the first database? What does
this say?
No. It just wants the.net.
We're gonna leave that right there.
It does
have
oops.
I see a
cert equals
something.
So we're gonna have to work that one
out. Now, when I created the Atlas
when I created the Atlas cluster,
it did
create a user and gave me
in X five zero nine.
Let's grab that.
Here.
So that gave me some sort of pen
for me to handle the authentication.
I suspect this may be what we require.
However, we're gonna find out.
It doesn't appear like it's telling me
what that is.
So let's let's continue to go through the
docs and see if it's explained a little
bit later.
So, in fact, there's this not yeah. It's
now telling me how to get that URL.
Wonderful.
Always read the documentation first before wandering off
in your own path. That's usually a pretty
solid idea.
Okay. So we got we did get that.
We got this
and then the atlas cacert. So MongoDB Atlas
uses certificates sent by Let's Encrypt.
So we have to download the Let's Encrypt
root certificate.
There we go.
So let's copy
the address
curl
output
CA.
And that should be okay,
which means that our DB proxy
is going to use
root CA.
Yep.
And
what's next?
Oh, that's it. Alright. Let's try it.
Bash
DB proxy.
It's running.
Haven't authenticated myself in any way, but it's
definitely running.
Alright. What's next?
So now we have to configure Atlas. So
we can
we've we already created one of these.
Wonder if that host is important.
Okay.
It's not important. It tells me we can
probably reuse the one from earlier.
And then we go to advanced
and we add the content. Yeah. We add
our certificate. Okay. Got it. We're adding the
certificate authority generated by Teleport
as an accepted
means of authenticating
with MongoDB Atlas.
I guess this would work really well if
your organization
already has authentication
solved as a problem
via OAuth, SAML, other search,
active directory, whatever the hell they're doing,
that you can actually just bring this into
the system.
So what do we need to do?
Well, we need to pop back on
to my server.
And that one's a bit busy, so I'm
gonna leave that as is.
Pop this open
and do a cat
mongocas
and
copy paste.
So if we come to here
and go to advanced,
self managed.
The
next thing we need to do is create
a new database user using the MongoDB UI,
and that probably gonna
sped out.
I'm gonna spout out anything, it's just gonna
work.
Alright.
Let's go for it.
Add a new database user, certificate based, of
course, because we've added our new CA. So
Teleport can now issue its own certificates for
the users that it wants.
It's telling us that our common name could
be anything that we wish.
So
I will do Rawkode
Atlas,
and I'm gonna give it rewrite to any
database
and go.
It's deploying our changes.
I guess we should wait for that.
Configuring MongoDB.
So I
don't really think I mean, could go into
the documentation and find out for sure, but
I don't think we really need to do
anything else. And I feel like I just
wanna try it. So
if we do an LS list, we're gonna
have our MongoDB proxy that we configured.
I think we can do a DB login
where I specify the users, the common name
that I added,
and the name of the DB proxy is
no different.
I think this will work regardless. I think
that's just set some config.
We'll do TSLS
again.
We can see that's configured.
And then
wanna do a MongoDB connect
because I called it MongoDB.
Am I gonna get it? Oh,
dreads.
User not found.
I
was kinda confident that was gonna work.
Let's follow the docs.
No. Not fair. I took that.
Okay. They're just they're just connecting straight. Okay.
Let's see if we can work out what
went wrong.
Oh.
Alright.
Let's purge that proxy.
Oh, hold on a minute. That's connecting
hey. Come on, audience. You should have well
pointed this out. So first, I've got two
URIs, and there's no new line separator here.
Well, that was never gonna work in a
million years.
And if we run this now,
it seems happy.
And if we run this one, oh, I
wonder if Danny's logging in again because of
the proxy.
I'm not sure.
No. Okay. That's from local state, what it's
doing.
And I'm gonna get a shell.
So
that would have worked.
I believe I believe you.
Okay. I can run
the admin command, but that's okay.
That is awesome. We are now connected to
MongoDB Atlas. And again, it really wasn't a
lot of effort.
All we had to do was create a
user and add
the
certificate authority generated by Teleport as external authentication.
This is cool because this means
that I can come into the oh, that
IP address did work.
Let me check the IP address of this
machine.
IP.
Where's the public address?
That's interesting.
Well, in theory,
I should be able to remove my IP
address.
Redeploying.
And my Mongo command from here should still
work because we're going through the proxy on
the server,
which means that you only really need
to expose
your
you only need network access to your MongoDB
Atlas cluster from the Teleport server.
So we've got a boom from Russell.
Yeah. I'm pretty happy that worked as well.
And a question from was, the Bind IP
on Atlas should match the Teleport server port.
Correct?
No. I said in the documentation, it it
didn't matter
about the the Bind IP address here because
we are
because we are actually giving MongoDB Atlas the
certificate authority generated by Teleport.
So there's kinda carte blanche access from that
point, and Teleport is just gonna work with
its own service.
So it doesn't matter if the certificate generated
doesn't have the same IP address, or it
doesn't have the same domain name.
Alright. Let's just do that
now that that's deployed.
Yeah. Okay. That still works. That's good.
I guess the real question is, will it
break?
If there's no network access, then my mom
would be cluster. If this still works, then
the last two things I did were absolute
pointless. But I'm still happy that we got
that configured. And again, really easy.
Just good documentation from the Teleport project.
I'm not winging anything else though.
Once we've tested this one, I just wanna
see this field hopefully,
and then I'm calling it quits for today.
It's not this thing seems
quite cool.
Not something I've played with a lot, but
it does have a free tier, which I'm
using right now, where I can just spin
up a MongoDB, like on a shared cluster,
which is pretty
cool.
All right. Configure, configure, configure.
I'm done.
Yeah. That's failing.
That's cool.
Timed out. And that's just because the server
now hasn't accepted access from anywhere. So I
could go back and add the IP address
of my Teleport server and that would work.
So that's pretty sweet.
There's a great closing comment from Russell. Teleport
securing the world. Definitely feels like it these
days, doesn't it?
Sweet. All right. That's it for today. We've
now done database access for Postgres, we've done
database access for MongoDB.
We will be back next week.
There'll be more tutorials as we dive into
some smaller concepts like GitHub authentication
on Teleport OSS.
So I'll be showing you how you can
you know, every time I've created a user
in Teleport, we've used this Teleport control and
created local users. We're gonna be using GitHub
and GitHub
teams within organizations
as a means to give access to our
servers. So we'll be checking that out next
week.
All right, thank you for joining me. I'll
post a few comments up as I say
goodbye, but always a pleasure. I'll see you
next week. Have a great weekend. Thank you.